افاد الجيش الاسرائيلي بمقتل مستوطن في
اطلاق نار بمنطقه الاغوار جنوب البحر
الميت وقال الجيش ان مسلحين كانوا يستقلون
سياره اطلاق النيران على سياره اسرائيليه
ثم واصلوا طريقهم نحو اريحا واطلقوا النار
هناك على سياره ثانيه
وافادت التحقيقات الاوليه ان المسلحين
احرقوا سيارتهم ولاذوا بالفرار نحو مدينه
اريحا
[موسيقى]
وقد اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال
ساعات الماضيه ثمانيه فلسطينيين على الاقل
في مناطق متفرقه من الضفه الغربيه وقد
اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال بلده يعبد في جنين
واعتقلت ثلاثه شبان بينما اعتقلت ثلاثه
اخرين في مخيم العروب للاجئين الشمالي
مدينه الخليل ونقلت قوات الاحتلال جميع
المحتقلين الى مراكز للتحقيق معهم في
قضايا تتعلق بمقاومه الاحتلال
كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مخيم
شعفاط في القدس المحتله فجر اليوم واظهرت
صور بثها نشطون مجموعه من قوات الاحتلال
تتجول داخل احد احياء المخيم وقال المركز
الفلسطيني للاعلام ان قوات الاحتلال
اعتقلت شابا عقب اقتحامها المخيم
واقتحمت قوات من شرطه الاحتلال ايضا بلده
العيساويه شمال شرقي القدس المحتله
وحاصرت منزل المواطن زكريا محيسن وشرحت في
هدمه بحجه عدم حصول صاحبه على ترخيص
للبناء
في غضون ذلك على جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تعزيز قواته في منطقه نابلس الشماليه
الضفه الغربيه بكتابه عسكريه رابعه ياتي
القرار عقب مشاورات اجراها وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يؤنت مع قياده الجيش خلال جوله
تفقديه في موقع عمليه حواره التي اسفرت عن
مقتل مستوطنين اثنين
من رام الله ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
سميره بوشماله سمير اخر التطورات وكيف
يبدو المشهد اليوم
يعني نبدا وسيله بما يجري في بلده
العيساويه الواقعه شمال شرقيه مدينه القدس
المحتله حيث اقتحمت قوه من شرطه الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه البلده وحاصرت منزل الاسير
المحرر زكريا محيسن في البلده وايضا
اصطحبت معها جرافات وبدات بعمليه هدم
المنزل للمره الثانيه
في هذه المنطقه وذلك بحجه عدم الترخيص
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه في الضفه
الغربيه هي ما زالت تطبق ايضا الخناق على
اليوم الثاني على التوالي على مدينه اريحا
على جميع المداخل والمخارج وذلك بعد تنفيذ
هجوم مسلحه ادى الى مقتل مستوطن اسرائيلي
يحمل الجنسيه الامريكيه حسب المصادر
الاعلاميه وايضا مصادر الرسميه الاسبانيه
التي اعلنت عن ذلك منذ ساعات الليل الليله
الماضيه الجيش الاسرائيلي يقوم بعمليات
تدقيق
وتفتيش بالمركبات وهويات المواطنين ويقوم
ايضا بعمليات توقيف للسيارات ولكن لم يتم
هناك اقتحام للمدينه حيث ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يشتبه بان منفذي اللغه الهجوم
يوم امس قد دخلوا الى مدينه اريحا ولكن
حتى هذه اللحظه لا توجد عمليه ملاحقه داخل
المدينه ولكنها اطبقت الخناق على المدينه
لليوم الثاني على التوالي هناك كان ايضا
اغلاق لمعبر الكرامه والمؤدي الى المملكه
الهاشميه الاردنيه
للمغادرين من المسافرين وايضا بالتزامن مع
ذلك هناك ايضا بعض الحواجز العسكريه ما
زالت قائمه في محيط مدينه نابلس وتقوم
بعمليه التفتيش في تلك المنطقه بعد يومين
شهد العديد من الاعتداءات من قبل
المستوطنين الاسرائيليين على ممتلكات
ومنازل وايضا الاعتداء بالضرب على
المواطنين الفلسطينيين ادت الى اصابه
العشرات منهم
بجروح وايضا احراق العديد من ممتلكاتهم
خلال هذه الاعتداءات في بلده سلواد شرقيه
مدينه رام الله كان هناك ايضا محاوله من
قبل مجموعه من المستوطنين كانوا ملثمين
حسب شهود العيان قد دخلوا الى بلده سلواد
الليله الماضيه ولكنهم عندما توقفوا عند
طريق المسدود تم اكتشافهم وهربوا الى
معسكر
لجيش الاحتلال قريب من المنطقه ولكن
الشبان قاموا باحراق المركبه التي كان
يستقلها هؤلاء المستوطنين وبعدها كان هناك
دخول واقتحام لاحدى الدوريات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه الى داخل البلده وقامت قام
الشبان برشقها بالحجاره من مسافه سفر دون
ان يبلغ عن وقوع اصابات بين الفلسطينيين
او الاسرائيليين كل هذه التطورات ايضا
جاءت في سياق ايضا شعور
الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي اصدر بيان وتحدث به
بانه يشعر بالقلق الكبير ازاء هذه ما وصفه
بدوامه العنف بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين خلال الايام الماضيه وطالب
الجانبين بالتدخل الفوري والعجز هذه
الدوامه شكرا جزيلا لك سميره ابو شماله
مراسلنا من رام الله